ilhan Omar who is a Somali immigrant
first generation immigrant into the
United States uh here she is reminder
Gaza doesn't have shelters or an Iron
Dome and to please pray for them may
peace Prevail in the region and move us
towards a moral Awakening to care about
human suffering we are seeing
Palestinians are human beings who have
been besieged and are deserving of
protection from the International
Community Palestinians are besieged
she's right by Hamas there's not one
Israeli that lives in Gaza they
completely moved every Israeli out there
were about 8,000 Jews living there
Hitler would love the place there's not
one Jew Hamas took over they killed
their opposition and for all of these
years all of the billions and billions
of dollars that Hamas got and what did
they build they clearly built an an
incredibly effective Guerilla Army
instead of building say bomb shelters or
an Iron Dome or anything else she's just
a communist I don't know how to say it
any other way